how do we always get into this
[Music]
fall back
nothing out get me on the roof
thank you layla
you better have a plan jacob don't miss
so that was fun
[Applause]
welcome to red falls
redfall is our effort to take what
arcane does well a hybrid of
first person games and rpgs
and stretch ourselves a little bit
does this work in the open world does it
work
both solo and with co-op players
can we take all our narrative layers and
our
improvisational mechanics and our style
and spread that out across an open world
for me red fall represents our most
ambitious title that we've tried to do
here in the austin studio ever
it was super important for us to you
know let players still play by
themselves and have that sort of like
immersive arcane experience but
but then adding three other players up
to three other players into the mix of
course changes everything not only from
the player experience standpoint but
just from develop the development
standpoint also the reason i like making
the kind of games that we make is
because i like playing these kind of
games right and so like
it's the same reason i like tabletop
rpgs too
and it's it's the the allure of like
i want to witness and then mess with
some dramatic scene i want to come upon
these tableaus and and sort of like
almost a hand farm-like like see what's
going on hear what they're saying
try to suss out what they're doing and
then i want to like jack with it in some
way you know going to turn the vampire
loose on them or put explosives down or
snipe them from a distance you know or
see some cultist fortress like real far
away and try to figure out how am i
going to get in there you know what am i
going to find when i get in there you
know
that kind of stuff is like super
enticing to me
some of my favorite moments are just
like
sort of observation about how the world
changes the way we spawn different
little vignettes across the world
and you catch people at different points
on their patrol route and day night
changes things and
it's uh that's a powerful piece to me is
like wow i feel like i'm in a living
world yeah
i'm really excited about the setting of
the town of redfall you know it's like a
lot of games you think it's not new york
it's not you know london or boston or
whatever you know it's it's quaint it's
small even though it's our biggest game
it's uh it feels like small town
americana and you know to your point
harvey with the time of day like that
you can run through this open world so
many different times but based on the
time of day based on different like
weather if the fog has rolled in it can
feel so dramatically different each time
and with the the random spawning it's
you're constantly on your toes and in
awe of some of the ways that the world
looks
i really gravitated toward a lot of the
narrative that's in the world you know
the readables and getting just caught up
and just like i'm going to read this
thing now and
or like walking through the ford
encampment and seeing a framed newspaper
and then getting close and realizing the
full story is actually there something
that makes sense yeah and then you turn
around and that person they're talking
about is in this picture frame behind us
um that in the
forcing myself to take different
approaches uh i specifically remember
kind of going through and i have my one
way i go for the first mission every
time this is the way i go across this
bridge go up there
watching somebody else go down uh into
the lake bed and there's a cave there
that i had no idea just like completely
blew my mind after the chopper's
crashing yeah
i was even thinking i was watching
they're going the wrong way that's not
how you that's not how you go but they
kind of change how i approach everything
now where i feel like i i have the way
that i think about and then i'm you know
actually going to go this way this time
and it feels compelling to do that so
yeah if i could add anything to that or
if i could put it into one word it would
probably be like uh transported like we
put so much effort into the narrative
into the world building environmental
storytelling all that stuff that i
and it's part of the reason the games
that i gravitate towards make me feel
that way you know
so i hope players feel like they've been
transported to some place that like
feels real at the end of the day yeah
it's like that moment in time that you
feel these people have existing
relationships that you're kind of being
a part of they're not just people just
happen to pop up you know randomly yep
and uh one word we've used for this game
throughout the whole time is spooky you
know we're not like a horror game so i
hope people there's not jump scares per
se right like
yeah but uh so i hope people feel like
you know they can take the time to
explore but they also there is still
that edge that there could be anything
right around the corner so you're not
necessarily standing up in your seat uh
from fear but hopefully there's that
little bit of
spooky element that you just never know
what you're going to encounter
the story of red fall begins with this
idea that these like
really smart wealthy biotech
entrepreneurs came to the island they
weren't from the island originally they
bought up some property and they started
doing some research into like longevity
experiments and life extension and
things like that probably seeing stuff
like that in the news recently with
people doing weird stuff with biotech
startups but and that you know uh
started to go south really quickly get a
little like morally questionable you
know without giving spoilers away the
end result was they turned themselves
into vampires
and one of the distinctives about our
game is that
the vampires in our game and the
vampirism that they have is not uh it's
not a disease it's not an accident it's
not something that you can cure
it's not like oops i got a cold and let
me take this medicine and get rid of it
and now i'm back to my normal kind self
or whatever the people who became
vampires and people who become vampires
in our game in a sense they already were
vampires on the inside right it's more
like a metamorphosis not a disease that
they caught and so it is it's definitely
this like horrible evil that's like
taking hold of the island that needs to
be resisted and fought
not it's they're not innocent people
that you're trying to save and they
slowly like a frog boiling water they
slowly took over the town and
consolidated all the power and that's
where players find themselves now at the
beginning of the game
we wanted to do something that was
recognizable as vampires but
but also a fresh take
or a less common take
um so
you know if they don't have fangs and
they're not afraid of the sun and they
don't drink blood then they're not
vampires they have to have those
elements to be vampires basically
but we wanted our vampires to be derived
from science
um but we wanted to avoid the crosses
garlic uh
running water kind of stuff and in lieu
of like
uh these are vampires that wanted this
to happen to them they wanted to
live forever even at the expense of
other people even if it requires the
blood of others they're horrible
monsters none of them are romantic
interests or you know aspirational you
know they they are i mean maybe you're
right they're like they're
beautiful most of them are beautiful
they're aspirational it's like what they
envision themselves that they're just
like they're great like their own ideals
they're manifesting
fancy clothes and you know they're
they're stylish it's like what they they
themselves envision themselves as
idealized predators yeah
and people who play the game will see
the ecology
of the sort of boot-looking cultists
that follow them that want to be made
vampires and
um
[Music]
you know the the the humans that have
been converted
the vampires can modify them in
different ways
um
[Music]
not all of them become vampires uh
nothing as grandiose as that some of
them become like different types of
familiars that are part of the gameplay
ecology all the way up to the vampires
and then sort of like specialized
versions named versions
like the vampire underbosses and things
like that and then we have a series of
vampire gods which are the most twisted
most changed by the whole process
uh and those serve as sort of chapter
break points across the game
um and the gods are the vampire gods are
like the they have the most power
they're the ones trapping you on the
island right they've pushed the waters
back they're the ones that have blacked
out the sun um
they're uh they're tremendously powerful
i really latched onto the idea of them
being
dangerous people regardless kind of like
you were saying like they're
irredeemable in that they're they're
just being unleashed and you know
they're you're showing their true self
at this point right for me the uh the
cult just gave me a really nice view
into the vampires because we were
talking about how they've already kind
of
become their worst self but i think
through some of the conversations with
the cultists you get to discover what
that actually means and just how
horrible you have to be to even just get
to that point
so yeah and then you can still end up
not being a vampire at the end of the
day so which is
in some ways showing the mirror of how
they are really awful because they may
not still turn you into the vampire yeah
like uh
harvey touched on this a little bit a
second ago but like the the vampires uh
you know
first of all the the cultist has to want
to become a vampire and then
the vampires have to share some of their
blood with them and so like you know so
i always
picture that like some of the cultures
are like i hope i get turned into like a
really badass vampire and then i can do
whatever i want but the vampires can
choose instead to turn them into these
other horrible things uh like one of
them is called a blood bag which is just
like this grotesque creature that it's
like
it's like a
vampiric version of a milk cow but it's
just it just produces like excess you
know bloated amounts of blood for the
vampires to to sip on whenever they're a
little thirsty but i love the the
writing for the blood bags is that they
exalt in it they don't
look look at me i'm gorgeous yeah
the four heroes that you get to pick
from to play
deliberately you know we set out to say
some of them are from the island some of
them are outsiders coming into the
island so you have multiple perspectives
and they represent this like spectrum of
like different backgrounds different
play styles like you know if you're
like i gravitate towards jacob who is
like um
probably more stealth oriented because
he's got the ability to turn invisible
he's kind of got a sniper
type skills he's got a raven that can
scout for him
and all the way on the other end of the
spectrum you've got somebody super wacky
like defender who's like uh got a bunch
of crazy gadgets um that allow him to do
bizarre things like you know
plant uh javelins on the ground that
spark lightning everywhere or teleport
around
um or he can he has a black light power
let's freeze everyone so he's got a lot
of like uh
area of effect abilities and
personality-wise he's just like uh he's
just super gregarious and interesting
and just like zany character he's
internet famous you know cryptid hunter
um so i think there's like
with the four heroes there's a little
bit of something for everyone um
you know depending what your play style
is and what kind of you gravitate
towards in terms of like personality
yeah and the funny thing about defender
is i think he actually wants to be on
the island to be researching what's
happening
yeah that's true he's he's happy that
at some level he's happy that something
crazy like this is happening because it
validates his like theories or whatever
i think it's also fun to think about who
and why are they on the island you know
like layla was living here she was a
college student defender was here for a
book signing right lucky him to actually
have some content to capture uh remy you
know from some of the tricklings of some
weirdness happening she's here because
of her search and rescue uh skill set
and jacob initially with bellwether so
jake was one of the bad guys you know
so to have such to really think about
really
different reasons for these characters
to be here on the island and then build
up from that was fun as well i think
something i struggled with initially but
i've come to really appreciate is that
they're not they're not a kid this isn't
just this is the tank and then this is a
healer and this is this you know there
there's so much nuance to how you play
each of these characters like you know
defender it would be really easy just to
say he's the gadget guy but that doesn't
really encapsulate everything that he
can do he has a little bit of crowd
control a little bit of traversal you
know and then like you know a big aoe
um versus like
uh you know remy has you know grip on
with her and that kind of has a a lot
going on there
but then also has you know her sticky
bomb and like um
that that's really given me a lot of
like joy to kind of discover how i want
to play these characters and beyond just
like the high level summary of them
so as you're playing through the game uh
of course there are um
you know we've come up with a suite of
like really cool abilities and powers
for players to choose from just like we
did in pray and dishonored you have
tons of options
and if you know if you happen to be
playing as like like if we all decide to
play layla's or jacob's um
you know my jacob might not be the same
as yours because um i may i may choose
to like really drill down into the the
the raven skill tree and like max that
out
before i pick any of the other skills
um so you got a lot of choice there um
to like express different play styles um
that's the skill trees but then of
course you've also got your gear like
we've got special things called remnants
you can find which are like basically
magical vampire blood that you can equip
almost as like a talisman that uh will
give you special uh resistances or
special abilities related to healing but
it also boosts you know
your health
so there's lots of different ways that
you can sort of customize your your
character's build yeah and there's also
ways for
your friends to if you've leveled up
certain skills to a certain point that
your friends get to benefit from them
yeah like if you're playing jacob and
you level up cloak to a certain point i
actually can cloak as well yes we we
tried to not make it so that like this
skill only works in multiplayer or this
skill only is useful in single-player
but like but it has the single-player
benefit but then it has the multiplayer
like ad and if you happen to be playing
with friends it does cool stuff for your
friends too which i think is gonna be
super fun
[Music]
i thought as like in a horde shooter
like they're coming for you at all times
you feel that pressure and in this game
i feel like like i'm the danger kind of
thing right i'm the one who's moving
through you're trapped in the room with
me
it's also important that that's a great
point and it's important to note that
like
they're unaware of you so you can zoom
in and eavesdrop on their conversations
you can sneak up and listen to two
people talk and then slip away from the
encounter
uh you know it's it's it shares the
lineage of arcane games in that sense
yeah that's something that's also been
nice about the vampires being the the
antagonists is that they're not mindless
they're not just let me run and eat your
brain right so they're actually
thoughtful they are a bit more of a
predator uh and also humans are
terrifying right so the cultists in
bellwether are
they're they're also more tactical so
yeah they take cover you know they
flank you all those good things
well the other thing is like
this is an open world game you're never
trapped in like i'm not trapped in this
alley and i have to defeat 30 you know
it's going to hold up yeah i don't have
to hold out like i can do the thing that
i do in other um
open world games which is like
this monster's too hard i'm leaving and
i'm gonna go fight these other monsters
over here get a new weapon level up and
then i'm gonna come back and kick this
guy's ass
when we started uh redfall we
knew we needed like you know guns
because this is part rpg part shooter
and it was fun to be able to work with
modern guns for once
um
and
you know we wanted a range from like
high-end military gear dropped by
bellwether security on the island all
the way down to like grandpa's shotgun
found in the attic
of this old victorian house
um
and then some kit bash stuff too like in
his garage this this person made like
you know a duct tape handgun that you
know
has a flashlight on it or something
right so there's there's ranging from
jury rig to high-end military and all
that
um but very quickly we realized we also
needed some vampire specific weapons and
so
the uv beam which leads to a whole
system of petrifying the vampires from
which they can thaw out if you don't if
you don't stake them the stake launcher
itself which is like a found
ammo type weapon like broken off pool
cues and snapped off mop handles and
fireplace pokers and things like that
steak knives
yeah and then like flare guns which
you'd find on a tourist island with
sailboats and all
uh they emulate vampires and so they
become like a little fireball launcher
and so the usual weapons that you that
you love in games sniper rifles and
shotguns and
uh assault rifles and things like that
are fun to play with in our game and
they
level up over time and they have
different traits on them and so you're
looking for the one with the right
traits that you want and they have
stakes on the end of course because
you'd be yeah steak vampires right again
every time we tweak our fiction in some
way like vampires it leads to whole
systems like staking and petrification
with uv light and all that but but in
addition all those guns we have the the
set of vampire specific guns that are
that are
you know unique to the game the best
steak attachment in the game is the uh
is the garden gnome
yeah
i'm partial to the harpoon it looks like
a whaling harpoon that's been cut off
and put on the end of the rifle so
[Music]
we start with something really
weird uh and fantastic right like
dunwall or space station
and then we work to make it uh so the
players can understand the space and
learn about the environment but this
time we started with something familiar
on purpose like everybody gets like a
small town
you know on the east coast everybody
understands liquor stores and
convenience stores and clinics and
neighborhoods
so that part is awesome because you're
immediately dropped into something you
understand but then
the part that i like is then we twist it
right the vampires
they have they warp reality around them
with their psychic abilities so
uh the cult is of course build weird
structures on top of the familiar
settings that you'll encounter
occasionally and then
the vampires like punch these holes uh
through reality and make these little
pocket dimensions where they like sleep
and gather power uh and those spaces are
some of my favorite because everything's
just like bent and twisted into this
like sort of halloween slash nightmare
version of reality and speaking to the
size i think the talus and prey was five
football fields and the size of breath
falls kind of hold my beer on that one
so we definitely challenged the whole
team with making something this big yeah
i remember early on there was a moment
we were working on district 2 which is a
little more rural
and uh
jim mcgill took
talos at scale and dropped it in the
middle of the farm that's there
and the district just eats the whole
space station of course it's gigantic it
was just the size of the actual like
farm area yeah and that's just like one
mission yeah that's pretty crazy
ultimately we hope that players will
play
single player if that's what they want
and it will feel like an arcane game
but it's more expansive it's an open
world but it's not an open world based
on the scale of vehicles it's an open
world based on foot and so it's like a
familiar setting new england spooky
traverse the the place go into mom and
pop grocery stores apartments get on the
roof of buildings
and we try to put as many environmental
storytelling scenes around as we
possibly can
um
and so it just feels very lived in i
think the thing that's compelling to me
about the open world
and this is true in other open world
games that i love but um it's just like
how easily the player can get distracted
you know with like some other wondrous
thing or some interesting point of
interest like you always set out with
like i have this goal in mind i'm going
you know to the shipyard or the farm to
rescue this person or collect this thing
that's my mission but like it takes me
two hours to get there because
along the way like a nest popped up or i
saw a vignette with some like cultists
who were harassing some civilians that
are tied up or
i got ambushed by vampires you know
or an npc gave me a little side mission
to go check out um
there's always something along the way
that just like pulls me off the off the
beaten path
to check something out or discover
something or loot something
and that's just tremendously fun
i'm thankful every day for
like arcane is a company where some of
us have worked together for 20 plus
years or 10 years or you know and
there's a lot of cement there socially
and a lot of creative chemistry and
uh even though some people have left and
new people have joined us and all that
it's been uh
it's been a blessing to have this team
and this game and
the company culture and we're in it
together we're going to get through this
we're going to ship our game no matter
what no matter what virus hits us or
whatever you know so
but during this last few years it's been
a blessing
[Applause]
play it day one with game pass